regarde regarde regarde
je vais en quelque sorte au moment où elle écrit dessus pour
ton écarlate seulement vas-y nous allons te le
mettre par le oui correspond négatif nous pouvons
donc nous avons juste envie de vérifier ici
six disent probablement à Roger lubob l'espace aérien le
plus grand  le service se termine ne sera pas un
poste gratuit pour des dollars tuez-le en
me moquant de moi nous jouerons au hockey en
deuil c'est sûr
que c'est la goutte que je n'ai jamais eu à
compter auparavant
mais on ne sait jamais qui semble
bouger un peu nous pensions  qu'ils
gardent dr.  avant ou quelque chose
comme ça, certains ont pensé oh vous savez, ne
gardez pas la solution cool
et avez une solution chimique de Dewar et de l'
eau bien vous Velveeta - quoi de neuf ma
solution chimique maison ouais que d'autres
hélicoptères de maison partout là-bas j'ai
quelqu'un d'autre  ce haut ou pas ouais hé
juste tuer le temps sur une visite touristique
bien d'
accord pouvons-nous aller nous faire saucissonner hors du
bâtiment pouvez-vous voir Times Square d'
ici on va finir par là je
regarde aller un peu à gauche et
toi '  re baissez un peu poussez un peu vous
prenez le carré du temps vous verrez le
magasin de tatouage pensez-vous euh ouais mais
regardez voir où j'en parle
juste un peu vert mais ouais ouais je
n'aime pas je  je l'ai eu ici d'accord j'irai
là-bas voir ce que nous pourrions voir de la compagnie afin que
nous regardions en haut le tout à fait
bon travail bonjour la tour du gardien bel
angle nous allons juste travailler en orbite
ici environ quatre cinq minutes supplémentaires par
photo
je le ferais  aime bien faire
les choses  Parce que l'Empire va
devoir écrire, je vais le faire approcher
suffisamment de fois que nous avançons vers le nord sur
Central Park.
ne vous inquiétez pas,
lancez-le quelques fois
grâce à Paul, vraiment d'accord,
le bon homme de Paul, très peu de bonnes personnes
après cette affaire d'hélicoptère derrière moi
et il en est un,
il est un garçon de la campagne quand un gars méchant
qui imprimera des dollars pour que vous
sais ce que c'est un plaisir là tu sais
quoi Pete qu'est-ce que je dois m'asseoir ouais je
fais un coup avec un mort cette petite
caméra ouais ouais et j'ai j'ai la
balle
ouais à l'heure juste en
dessous je suis arrivé ici je  Je vais essayer la petite
fenêtre, il y a du vent, mais les images dans
le petit appareil photo sont meilleures que ratées, cela
affecte un Pete,
non, vous ne savez jamais, c'est un peu le même
plan que vous faites, mais j'ai la
boule Cineflex dessus.
patinoire ou quoi que ce soit semble
bien ce n'est pas ouais t  il un YouTube
comme ça, c'est des coupes assez cool et
analytiques,
je ne pense pas que oui, d'accord,
une fenêtre un peu délicate ordinaire semble foudroyée
parce que ce genre de diapositives
un peu comme ça mais je vais l'aligner dans
nous allons  frappe ou est-ce qu'il est un
peu surexposé ou fais-le moi savoir quand tu es en
direction du nord je regarde un peu je ne
vois pas beaucoup de gens dans les rues pas
manger en regardant beaucoup de
fans égoïstes comme cette pédagogie Taran je dis
sans  ceci comme la transition vers le
sud à travers le bas serré et une autre
preuve
le trébuchet un autre bon frère
je veux dire ce sont les zones où vous
verriez beaucoup de gens avec moi
comme ici et c'est doublement rafraîchissant
et là vous allez
allégoriquement enlever ça  garage tu
quittes Broadway par le service
Jermaine squawk VFR fruité beaucoup de
monde dans la rue je porterai plainte demain
au revoir Paul peux tu faire braquer dommage bien
qui dors bien encore
ouais désolé zoomin
que le maximum 99 faisons un peu de
t  herapy par dollar ceci lorsque nous
réduisons ma dette elle-même, les hélicoptères n'ont
besoin que de se déplacer un peu à gauche et à
droite et certains il y a une confusion de masse
qui manque probablement autour de toute la caméra
tout droit, regardez un peu
comme le peut-être aller un peu ça alors c'est
assez flou parce que c'est la
merde de ce genre de tomate bêta la plus lente
ici d'où nous
regardons notre angle d'une nuit Delta
aime continuer au nord de Central Park, vous
voulez aller au nord pour votre partenaire Robert
mm veux juste aller  pour le retour vers le
nord, il veut orbiter les Parkers
enlevez mes photos d'accord vérifiez les deux moitiés
juste à l'extérieur du parc là-bas, j'ai dit
avant de sortir, il y a tous les endroits
comme celui-ci
derrière ici, nous apportons la
descente de la rivière Hudson au tango  Delta
c'est tout, je marche juste vers le miel, remettez
seulement la fiction que vous verrez plus tard, je
reviendrai un sujet de plus que vous venez de jeter dans
les blagues 500 Islanders traffic I have
to take about the overhead rest 30 this
in
today wi  ce sera sept
ceux que vous reviendrez des
centaines de petits sujets le Skyhawk est
le meilleur des mentis doit être le sommet de
Central Park il n'est pas trouvé 850 tuiles
vous avez un rapide coup d'œil derrière ici
nous allons passer 200 pieds au-dessus à la
recherche  pour toi je resterai avec l'
enfer que je suis et il devait 75 - je sais